who loves the people look this way news
media a celebrity is throwing away his
hard-earned cash everyone pay attention
to me oh it's only $1 bills folks don't
bother
no it's still free spendable money this
is a huge story dollars I like the new
penny
yeah cash is for poor people what is
wrong with you bozos just riot over the
damn money already
well nothing to see here I guess oh
Jesus Christ
my ankle bring the alarm
irreplaceable pop icon an independent
woman Beyonce has been injured what more
can you give us details are sketchy at
this point but we do know beyonce is a
survivor and presumably she will keep on
surviving but what happened well Tom I'm
being told she fell on all the single
dollars all the single dollars all the
single dollars all the single dollars
all the single dollars Bills Bills Bills
we promise to provide live unflinching
coverage of this harrowing ordeal of a
star gone from dangerously love to
dangerously in peril don't stop watching
mr. peanut butter take her home
doctors have confirmed that Beyonce will
never perform again this just in a break
in the story of the Hollywood heist we
now go live to the house of mr. peanut
butter star of mr. peanut butters house
ah jeez what did that idiot - ladies and
gentlemen of the press I and I alone
stole the D from the Hollywood sign
just tell us why'd you do it oh I'll
tell you why I did it all for my
girlfriend Diane son of a bitch that
literal son of a bitch if you're joining
us mr. peanut butter has confessed to
stealing the deed for his girlfriend
Diane and what many are calling the most
romantic gesture in the history of
romance and gestures we now await the
LAPD's move the day they make love a
crime is the day I turn in my badge
[Applause]